this is like how many guitars I have way
too many for for how many how long I've
been collecting guitars I have like 35
or 40 guitars which is a lot of guitars
for like only three four years of
collecting what's up GQ I'm Shawn Mendes
and these are my essentials out of order
I have this Kevin Murphy hair piece that
I use this stuff is basically what I've
been using since I had hair basically
I switch between a couple this is my
favorite use your hair gets used to
paste after a while and then you have to
switch it up but this is the one that
works the best for me and smells the
best I think you know got to have the
hair looking good for photos and moving
on Tom Ford sunglasses this is the first
time I've ever traveled with the case I
was very happy with myself today I
always scratch them and if you scratch
these it's just like it's pointless to
have them these ones I've been through
too many it's not cool I keep losing
them but they're cool I just like how
they fit they're really nice quality
sunglasses and it feels like you're
looking through some like special lens
even though I'm sure they're no
different than any others fair
I used to wear other sunglasses but in
the last couple years has kind of been
Tom Ford for me I get super attached to
like items whether it's sunglasses or
you know watch our shoes or something
and then it's it's really randomly I'll
just switched my entire thing someone
would be like wearing a pair of
sunglasses and I'll try them on and then
I'll be on that for like two years I'm
super strict about the the lens coloring
I hate it when it's like a dark lens it
has to be like the sepia lens you make
the world look a little nicer yeah this
is a Louie Vuitton wallet it actually
has my initials as you can see oh now
you're gonna have to blur out all my
credit card information the story of
this is actually pretty cool it was one
of my best friend's weddings I actually
wrote him and his wife's first dance
song and I performed it while they
danced at the wedding and then kind of
as a present and a thank you they got me
this awesome wallet so that's pretty
good luck for me my friends from home
are pretty good they would actually
rather not hear me sing because they've
heard me sing my entire life but
definitely you know with newer friends
there's a lot of hey man you wanna sing
that song you wanna pick up the guitar
but it's cool I like to it's fun I
figured this would be kind of
interesting to bring to you guys so
these are called Quinton isotonix
actually Calvin Harris put me on these I
went to a studio and he had these in
this like this glass bowl and he was
like dude try them they're really good
for you and basically what it is is it's
a placebo I'm trying to read what
they're saying in the back so it's like
purified like seawater it sounds so
stupid it's like purified seawater and
minerals in here that's supposed to keep
you really healthy but basically it's
just fun because it's glass you break
one end
[Music]
drink it and then you put it back and
then I drink like four a day
if I die this is the reason or if I live
forever this is also the reason so if
you want to be a super placebo freak
like me and think this is making you
very healthy go for it Quinta nice and
calming the fan got me there's a
leather-bound book and this is a quite
new thing that I've been doing just like
at the end of the day writing down you
know what I want in life and then also
writing down what I'm grateful for I
think it's cool to kind of take time and
and just spend some time thinking about
those types of things so it's definitely
essential for me whether or not I'm
writing it every day it just feels good
to be able to when you want to write
down your thoughts if I remember
correctly I got it in Europe when I was
in Europe because I think I started
doing this when I was in Germany a fan
got this from me I wish I knew her name
whoever you are thank you I use it
I figured bring in the genes cuz I have
about 10,000 pairs of black skinny jeans
because it's whatever onstage and it's
what I wear 24/7 these are the pair of
our 13 jeans the classic distressed look
goes with everything man what you need
of these ones like 80 pairs of black
pants I know there's some people who
like don't wash jeans at all but I don't
know that's what you're supposed to do I
have no idea really I feel it makes you
did this look saggy if you want to keep
these skinny you gotta wash them and an
Armani shirt they're probably the most
comfortable long-sleeve or even t-shirts
you can wear and they're perfect for me
because long days of traveling on the
plane it feels like I'm just wearing a
nice comfy shirt so I'm obsessed with
them to look good too
I have this ring I got this in Japan is
from a store called sympathy of soul I
was trying to find something that was
very special I get very attached to
jewellery I think that it holds a lot of
you know lucky value and I can't take it
off now I think that it's all my luck
it's two Leafs oh you know what it is a
feather is take it back it's two
feathers
[Music]
this is one of my absolute favorite
items and I'm very proud and very happy
that I have it this is my ap it's like
my first real kind of watch collectors
watch I wear it pretty much every day
now I'm obsessed with it
I wasn't a watch guy for a long time
until I met John Mayer and he's
definitely he's probably the most watch
guy I've ever met and he actually was
the one who told me to get this guy so
yeah I started collecting watches about
a year ago and I'm definitely really
into them they look awesome
I wear boots for like a year until
they're like really really messed up and
then I switch them I think these are st.
Laurel I'm pretty specific with my boots
I'm never really wearing running shoes
outside of going to the gym so the boots
got to be comfortable and they got to
look nice and I really like these ones I
actually just scratched them yesterday
I'm not happy about that this case has
been through basically all the tours
with me you can tell because of all of
the fragile stickers from all of the
airports I used to try sneaking them
onto the planes but they're really big
and people get frustrated so yeah I
check them this case is a great case
though I bet I tore with this case
everywhere I go got this little thing
here that has all my info on it so I
can't lose it classic guitar case
[Music]
this is a 1959 Martin I got this
actually at a guitar Center in Hollywood
believe it or not I just love it because
it's very easy to play if I don't have a
guitar on me I would go insane because
if I have an idea and I can't get it
down I feel like I'm losing my best idea
so I kind of just decided like bring it
everywhere you go probably low soon
right now
yeah I'm obsessed with it actually my
favorite thing about this guitar is how
dead it is which for recording an album
is kind of perfect I got this like the
week before I started writing the album
so it's kind of fading a little bit for
me I find it has a very calming thing to
do especially like when I'm on social
media for a really long time and I'm
like what am i doing right now I just
pick up the guitar keep me entertained
for hours
[Music]
you